and theoretical computer scientists and
uh my talk today will not be a
mathematical one i'll just
present some uh conceptual uh ideas and
and uh data
so um recently it's become
clear from evidence that mutation is
affected by
complex biological mechanisms that
operate in the germline and by dna
sequence and structure
so what uh could this new knowledge
new empirical knowledge does it have
anything to tell us about
how evolution works so today
i'll discuss three seemingly unrelated
problems and how they may be connected
together by revisiting the question of
the nature of mutation
the first problem i want to talk about
is the way we use chance
in our explanations of evolution
in 77 jacob wrote the probability that a
functional protein
would appear de novo by random
association of amino acids is
practically
zero but since 2006
people have found genes that look as
though
they arise from uh from a junk what
what is presumably what presumably was a
junk sequence and non-functional junk
sequence and therefore
all the mutations that are accumulated
there um
must have accumulated uh people think
without selection
until one day there were enough signals
and coding sequences there that
there was suddenly a functional new gene
and how could this be especially given
jacob's
statement the answer it's been in the
air is that well maybe the nova genes
are small enough
and you know given that today we know
that there is much
transcription going on in the germline
maybe
by chance you know one once in a while
one of those minimal
transcripts would would acquire use
by accident but this is the paul de novo
gene it's 785 nucleotides
long in its shortest spliced form
so could this really arise by chance
let's talk about transposable elements
before you go to the maybe you should
tell them
what does the party that covered by
these secrets actually
right um for the most part we don't know
however for
the particular one for paulie there's
evidence uh
decent evidence that it is functional if
you disrupt it
it causes problems um and that's
about as much as we know we don't know
more about the functionality of it
but it seems to be important and that's
enough for
the point that it's an interesting job
just to understand this
does the structural fold of this party
look like
yet a great question
those are wonderful questions and i
think we could we could have
a full hour at least just discussing the
novel genes and
that would not be nearly enough
transposable elements which actually are
involved in the
origination and evolution of the novel
genes
were first described by mclintock in in
the 50s
and back then people mostly ignored it
because there was no concept
back in people's minds that the genome
it could be dynamic
but in time the novel gene started to be
discussed and in 76
dawkins was presented a
way of trying to to fit our
understanding of transposable elements
with
the traditional way of understanding
evolution according to which
transposable elements really are
virus-like parasites of the genome and
so they're not really part of
us and in the sense they they don't
disrupt our
traditional understanding of of the
genome
and this view was elaborated by
doolittle and others and important
papers that set the tone
for understanding of junk dna which is
riddled with transposable elements for
for many years and uh and they admitted
that you know
occasionally bits and pieces of these
genomic parasites can be co-opted for
host use by
by accidental chains but
in recent years it's becoming clear that
the contribution of transposable
elements to adaptive evolution is
immense
for example work from gunter wagner's
lab has shown
that that more than 1500
genes have been tied together
evolutionarily
into a novel complex genetic network
underlying a key adaptation
complex adaptation that is the
decidualization of the endometrium
in placental mammals and this happened
by
the movements of transposable elements
and many
and many mutations in them that
interacted together in a holistic
fashion
so you know a small piece of of
background
that i may have not said transposable
elements are these sequences that
move move around the genome or are
copied and pasted
around the genome and and uh maybe half
of our genomes are composed of them
in this example the transformative
element was carrying regulation around
was that yeah yeah so
it's it's the massiveness of this
example and others
and many other cases uh that tells us
these things are extraordinarily
important for adaptive evolution
could this be uh explained conceptually
by the movements of genomic parasites
and accidental mutations in them
moving on to encode
a large consortium of scientists that
has been studied the
the what was thought to be junk dna
intensively over several years and
announced
uh in september 2012 that the majority
of the human genome is active and needed
um what they consider the reversal of 50
years of thinking and that this finding
will revolutionize
our understanding of human biology the
human genome uh
and disease and ultimately medicine by
greatly increasing the scope
for uh genetical research uh that
ultimately will
uh will provide us with with
opportunities for medical intervention
and shortly after one of the
arguments main arguments that critics
used uh
um in in their criticism of encode
statements was that the amount of
variation drunk dna far exceeds the
amount of variation that could be
maintained by traditional natural
selection
nick barton just talked about this very
topic
and and that therefore all this
biochemical activity that encode
discovered since it couldn't be subject
to selection it must not have a function
and uh and therefore most of it there
must just be
chance associations of molecules uh
but what exactly do you mean by
biochemical activity
um i'll say this very briefly
to my understanding what this large
group of scientists are saying
is that they are seeing what looks to
them
like bits and pieces of biological
machinery
then they are assuming that they're
saying
they said that it has a function
and that's an open-ended statement
that's what it looks like to them
and then we come to uh we we bring
theoretical arguments to bear on this
topic
they're saying that they see things
sticking together if they see if they
see something sticking to it that's that
i mean they they say this themselves
hold on one thing so so in in biology
uh today uh there's a great debate over
there has been a great debate over these
results by encode people feel
passionately about this so you would
find people that that
that uh are very you know they feel very
strongly
that encodes findings are to a large
degree
um irrelevant for understanding of of
biology
and that they're misguided in a way and
that those
are chance associations of of molecules
okay and uh then there are people who
think that well maybe we don't
understand yet everything about how
things work and perhaps
there is merit to what these scientists
are saying that they are seeing
so let that let me let me continue
but can i just i mean there is an
argument one second let me finish my my
point
so if we look at at multiple
many very many observations of this sort
the innovo genes
the contribution of transposable
elements adaptive evolution
these observations that i just mentioned
by by encode but also many other things
we have the following question
how much how much accidental chance are
we invoking
in our explanations of adaptive
evolution
on the one hand we say that in general
we have an explanation for adaptive
evolution in the form of natural
selection
by this we implied that selection not
chance must be doing the
uh key part of the work of evolving
an adaptation but when we are faced with
the evidence and there are many
pieces of it very diverse
when we see any one piece we
we then take liberty to assume
that in addition to selection there is
also
just as much extra accidental chance
absent selection as we need in order to
explain the event
and the case and point is the novo genes
so let me move on to the second problem
how do genetic interactions evolve
fisher created a point of view
where selection acts on additive
variants and alleles as separate actors
each allele could be beneficial or
detrimental in and of itself with little
regard
of the genetic context that doesn't mean
that fischer was not interested in
interactions he was
but that was the perspective that that
emanates from his work
so right in contrast for assad the genes
interact in complex biochemical networks
which
today we know is obvious and he thought
that
we must explain genetic interactions and
clump
complementarity and the evolution of
complex genetic
networks so what did he propose then
how how did he think that complex in the
neck networks evolved
he proposed his shifting balance theory
according to which in the small
subpopulations
alleles in multiple laws i will not only
appear by accident but they in a sense
will also
spread by accident to fixation due to
random genetic drift once they're all
present
they can then interact fortuitously in
such a manner that will
allow them to serve as the basis for the
evolution of a new adapted
complex so you can see the connection
between the problem of genetic
interactions
and the problem of chance civil right
tried to solve
this big problem of how genetic
interactions evolved
and in so doing he opened the door
to our um unrestrained incense
unrestrained invocation
of accidental chance in explaining
adaptive evolution
so in a way there have been two core
ideas in 20th century
theory for how adaptive evolution works
one is selection acting mainly
on alleles as separate actors and the
other is the formation of the basis for
new genetic interactions
by pure chance besides this there have
been many models investigating the
effects of selection acting on
interactions within and between low side
but
those are in a sense corrections or
additions to the core ideas of selection
acting on
alleles and independent actors and the
formation of genetic interactions by
chance
in that sense there has been no proposal
for how selection acting on genetic
interactions can be at the core
of the adaptive evolutionary process not
in addition to something else that is
basic
the third problem what is the role of
sex and evolution
sorry
defined as the exchange of genes between
individuals that lead to
uh offspring that carry different
genetic combinations from their parents
that's the
evolutionary biological definition of of
sex or one that you can use according to
this definition
sex or genetic exchanges really seems to
be ubiquitous um
it occurs in plants and and in animals
through tsunami and in fungi
through the fusion of hyphae and in
bacteria by conjugation and
and other means in fact and
importantly it seems that obligate
asexual
species are not really species but
obligate asexuals
um are not only rare they also appear to
be
headed toward extinction over
evolutionary time it seems as though
they occasionally arise
from sexual ancestors and then
ultimately they seem to
go extinct so asex
is actually the derived condition the
ancestors are sexual
and already in 57 stevens concluded from
very extensive studies that obligate
asexuals don't seem to be capable of
evolving major new adaptations but only
of evolving minor changes
on themes inherited from sexual
ancestors
so sex requires so much effort
finding mates applying the whole the
whole the whole process and uh
and it requires highly sophisticated
adaptations today
um for its implementation from
human behavior to flowering and down to
the molecular
level and the machinery that is
responsible for for mitosis
so why sex this has been a big question
in biology so one common answer that you
might hear not from
experts in the field but it's still a
common intuitive answer people say as
well you know it's obvious sex generates
a great number of different combinations
of alleles across the loci
it's what makes individuals unique and
since selection acts an individual
variation
sex greatly facilitates evolution the
problem
with this quick answer is that what
what exactly does it mean is it that sex
will generate
so many different combinations so that
the best among them uh could be found by
selection
uh but then the problem is that just as
sex brings together
uh different combinations it also breaks
them down
they're not heritable and it is because
of this
that the sexual shuffling of the genes
uh it's because of it
that we focus on selection acting on
alleles
as as on single alleles or alleles as
separate actors
either we focus on that at the core or
we can also look at pure chances driving
the spread of
alleles at multiple lessons so why is
that why are those the only two choices
is it because we don't know how to deal
with the interactions or because
i'll examine one possibility so um so
here is a challenge that i want to write
um the assumption that each allele has
its own effect on the phenotype
in a sense made sex not too disruptive
to our theory but also
not essential and this restricted
us to asking uh whether and how it may
contribute to subsidiary benefit on top
of an evolutionary mechanism that works
essentially without it
can think of beneficial and detrimental
mutations as arising with or without sex
you can think of the selection
that we traditionally think of as
happening in asexuals or sexuals and
ultimately
um being just fine perhaps not
as good for reason unknown but
ultimately fine
and one problem all of these proposed
subsidiary benefits uh require specific
conditions that stand in contrast
to the prevalence of sex and nature so
three problems how much pure chance
without selection
are we invoking in our explanations of
adaptive evolution
another how do genetic contractions
evolve in another what is the role of
sex and evolution
i mentioned in the beginning now we know
mutation is affected by complex
biological mechanisms
operating in the germline nanolili
homologous recombination
non-homologous end joining transposition
complex enzymatic processes that affect
point mutation
this is relatively recent knowledge um
and this uh new knowledge raises
yet another question why have we been
believing that the mutation that drives
adaptive evolution under selection
is accidental what is meant by
accidental
accident is a destruction for example
one example of disruption is radiation
so here is an example of a fact we know
that we can blast drosophila with x-rays
and kill it
by artificially induced mutation that
doesn't serve as
evidence that the mutations that drive
adaptive evolution
under selection are due to radiation
what about copying errors we hear that
phrase so much
so much we hear that the mutations in
the germline uh
are copying errors we hear it so much
that it seems as though this is an
obvious scientific fact that we all know
but copying error is not
a fact it's an interpretive phrase
the fact is that while some genes are
being duplicated
others undergo genetic change
and to say that that genetic change the
cause of it
is is copying error
is is an interpretation it's only one
possible interpretation in fact it's
based on a tested assumption
that the biological system is designed
as though
to make a perfect copy of the whole
genome
uh in fact we know that this acid
assumption is
is not right because the biological
system
doesn't appear to be designed to make a
perfect copy first of all because it's
sexual
so these are not
facts not evidence in support of accent
mutation
these are concepts ideas that have a
company 20th century
evolutionary thinking
if it's not evidence that tells us the
mutation is accidental
it seems that the problem is this
conceptual
issue and we have we've had a good
reason to think about accidental
mutation
if we believe that the ultimate source
of genetic variation can only be
either accident or lamarckism then
we're justified in choosing accident
because lamarckism
cannot serve as a general level
explanation for evolution
if we don't believe that it would work
in multicellulars
even if some of us believe that it could
work in specific cases doesn't serve as
a general level explanation
if we think that these are the only two
alternatives we should choose accidental
mutation
as the source but what if the mutation
that drives adaptive evolution under
selection is
non-accidental in an essential manner
for evolution and yet is not of the la
marquis and kai so that's the question
that i
asked myself already a few years ago and
today i want to
tell you what i'm proposing i propose
that we
revisit this question from square one
okay think about the nature of mutation
affection
if the germline mutation that drives
adaptive evolution is not
accidental then what does what would it
mean
then it's an outcome of biological
processes that belong
to the organism and if so then these
processes are specified by the genes
just like any other
processes in the organism which means
the genes interact not only in the
determination of the classical
trait like the eye or the ear but also
in affecting genetic change i wrote here
uh determination of genetic change i
don't mean it to be deterministic
in fact this goes back
it goes back to a less valiance uh
framework of evolvability
because really all i'm saying is that
mutation is an output
of a randomized algorithm
now if genes interact in the
determination of mutation then
mutation is an outcome of process that
combines information from alleles at
multiple loci
and writes the result of the combination
operation into one locus
the locus being changed by mutation
so this will be clear with the picture
here are um
several different loci and we see
that cis elements and trans factors come
together in a biological interaction
that part of the figure should be very
familiar it's
basic to our understanding of molecular
and cellular biology
what is not as familiar is this era of
mutation here
now what what does it mean it means that
mutation is a biological process that
takes information from
multiple loci and combines it
and writes the result of this
combination into a particular locus the
locus of mutation
and in so doing it creates a piece of
information that is heritable
it creates a new mutation a new allele
which is this b star and an allele
is uh is an elementary unit for the
sexual shuffling of the genes it is not
itself broken down
by this shuffling and what this means is
that um
even if this particular combination
of genes dark abc
will never see each other again due to
meiosis
due to sex even so
information from this combination lasts
and is transmitted to future generations
through the mutation that was derived
from this combination
and this uh offers a new point of view
i'm sorry did you lose the ancestral
yeah the combination itself is no longer
there
but the mutation is there and the key is
to think of that mutation
as an encapsulation of information flow
that's key
clearer if you gave us an example of a
molecular
mechanism and anyway wait one second the
less than interruptions the more likely
i will and i would love to give you
um so so so
this does present a new a new um a new
view
which is that uh selection acts on the
uh genetic combinations that are
continuously generated by
uh by sacs and uh the combination of
information from multiple osi by
mutation transmits information to future
generations from these genetic
combinations
in fact it transmits that information
precisely in accord with the fitness
of the individual as a complex whole
and this addresses the three problems
from the beginning from the beginning
from a unifying perspective the role of
sex really is after all to generate a
vast number of different combinations of
genes
this role is fulfilled in conjunction
with mutation being an outcome of a
biological process not simply accident
and this allows for the first time
selection on individuals as complex
holes
no lawmakism was invoked here whatsoever
so instead of the question of how much
accidental chances invoked in accounting
for genetic changes
which doesn't seem to be amenable to the
scientific method we have a very
different
question that is amenable to the
scientific method
what are the details of the molecular
mechanisms underlying germline mutation
so let's notice something again i spoke
of
les valence uh framework and and and
once again this
provides basically a computational view
of of mutation
and evolution because um mutation is a
is an event that has multiple inputs
from multiple alleles a different loci
and it has an output which is the
genetic change
mutation is a computational event
another thing
the output of one mutational operation
at one generation of course can serve
later
as an input into the computation of
another mutation
so for example consider these two
parents and
an offspring here are the genes of
one parent and the genes that it's going
to transmit to its gamete
and here is a mutational event these
genes and the mutation
are going to be transmitted to the
offspring of course there are
multiple multiple mutations in any one
individual
we now know and you can see that the
output of a mutational event in one
generation
can be an input into the mutational
event at another generation which means
that there is a network of information
flow across the genome
and over the generations from any one
gene
into many genes and from many genes into
any one gene and
and this information flow i argue
is relevant for the evolution of genetic
networks
how can you store these mutations they
disappear the mutations remain
but you cannot reverse them i mean you i
mean
no no no no no no the point isn't
definitely not to reverse anything we're
not trying to preserve
the combinations we're generated
generating them again and again and
again
but information is collected in computer
science a picture of
a network of information floor and
computation
would be would be a very normal thing
let me try to get to the examples that
eugene has won
so
fitness determines the probability of
information transmission
from the genotype the individual carries
but now the individual is evaluated as a
complex hole this is an interaction
based
framework okay interactions here are
at the core of the process there are no
addition or correction
to a process that's based on uh
individual effects
and this involves many conceptual
changes just very quickly an allele has
no value of its own
if we think about this carefully and
deeply it does change the way we
understand
uh phenotypic change for example how
does phenotypic change come to be shared
by individuals of
of the population in the traditional
theory it's very easy to see a mutation
occurs in a particular gene in a
particular individual
it provides a certain change in the
phenotype and then
if that change is good it spreads and
brings that change
along with it from an individual in
which it occurred to
everyone then another mutation could
occur and so on it's very easy to see
how individuals would come to share
macro scale phenotypic change but
under interaction-based evolution well
alleles still spread in the population
albeit inconsistently due to the complex
dynamics
some after a period of time some will
spread some will go extinct
new alleles will come up all those
alleles that have spread after a period
of time can
provide a new amount of information that
can underlie a trait the phenotypic
trait that is now shared by
everyone except that they did not bring
independent pieces of the phenotype from
the individuals in which they occurred
to everyone
they rather interact and what this means
is that the phenotype evolves
on the level of the population as a
whole one would need to
think about this for a while to see that
this
is this is a different concept in a
different view
again what about uh what about the
nature of the phenotypic change in terms
of
it being accidental or not i spoke about
mutation genetic change
is being caused not by accident but by
uh computation
and uh and what about what about the
phenotypic change that it causes
could that be accidental
well in the traditional theory selection
acts and independent alleles
uh an accidental mutation has its own
phenotypic meaning that's complete at
the moment of the appearance of the new
mutation
all that remains for selection to do is
to check whether this mutation is good
and bad or bad
and so selection is seen as an external
judge of a phenotypic meaning formed at
random before selection takes place
so traditional natural selection is
thought of as a slave
but under interaction based evolution
the phenotypic meaning of a single
allele that a single allele that is
spreading to fixation is going to depend
on other concomitant alleles
but how the frequencies of those other
alleles will change depends
back on selection and interactions which
means that selection itself participates
in the formation of the phenotypic
meaning of an allele
which means that selection is not an
external judge of a phenotypic meaning
predetermined at random
but is actually an active participant in
its formation
which means that the phenotypic meaning
of a mutation is not random to selection
because information from selection is
already in it
so interestingly under interaction-based
evolution the definition
the definitions of non-accent mutations
uh come together from
above and from below from the phenotypic
level and from the genetic level
both the genetic causes and the
phenotypic meaning of the mutation or in
a sense
not accidental and
i i would have liked to present to you a
small
sample of of evidence and i'll
try to show as much as as much as i can
and maybe we can take the five minutes
of the
of the discussion that was during my
time all right
so um rearrangement mutation
uh is is non-random we know
that it's caused by complex biological
mechanisms
uh and they can cause insertions
deletions translocations
and versions uh duplications and uh
and interestingly the this set of uh
complex mechanisms still under much
study
uh but all of these mechanisms we
already know
very clearly that they're guided to
their places of action
by uh homology between sequences and by
dna sequence
and structural features and also
interestingly
if we think about the evidence that is
unquestionable we
see that that
different sequences that are involved in
one mutational event
are likely to be functionally related
to each other which is just an
interesting deep fact
about genetic change um
that was rearrangement mutation which is
a huge category of things that
you could read you know a very large
number of papers to try to
get a sense of this new forest a new new
new world of evidence but
let's talk briefly about point point
mutation as well the prayer locus uh
mutation rate uh varies across the
genome
and uh here is one example of of
an interesting point mutation some point
mutations in humans are
uh occur in the cytosine of cpg
dinucleotides
and putting together the evidence it is
beyond any question that the location
of these mutations their occurrence is
determined
by complex enzymatic processes
in addition we also know that there is
adaptive relevance here because
the locations are determined by
methylation and
the change in the cytosine is going to
affect future methylation
methylation is important for the
functioning of the
organism through the its effects on
development
unless you think that that this is just
some small
um you know strange piece these
mutations account
for 25 percent of all point mutations in
humans so kind of
i don't understand what you mean by
non-random you mean that it's a
non-uniform distribution
non-random would be non-uniform
distribution non-accidental would mean
that it's not
it's not it's not uh you know
an agent that's in a sense external it's
not radiation it's not oxidative stress
it's not a copying error there's a big
system here that's evolved and
continually evolving
and it is clearly determining or
affecting
locations of genetic changes and the
nature of genetic change
the same way one second see more
examples and you'll get you'll get a
sense of how this works
um you know here is another quick little
piece coincident
single nucleotide polymorphisms these
are cases where in exactly the same
nucleotide and related species like
human and chimpanzee you would see a
variation
in the same location the people who
study this think
that selection alone cannot explain this
coincidence of variation in closely
related species
so they have looked for sequence motifs
in the location of these mutations to
explain their occurrence
and this is not enough they conclude
that it seems that
information from elsewhere must be
determining this which would fit
with my theory which predicts the
determination of mutation is complex
another example we uh we know today
that meiotic recombination occurs in hot
spots whose locations are determined by
the combinatorial effect of the binding
uh to transcription factor binding sites
of multiple
factors that interact with each other
epistadic
and so um we also know that meiotic
recombination hot spots
are also mutation hot spots this means
that in this case we have a
somewhat detailed example of a mutation
that we
see is determined exactly in accord with
the figure that i showed
here's another an interesting high level
fact
today we know that there are multiple
fundamental differences between the
genetics of the germline and the soma
for example
transcriptional promiscuity which people
have tried to invoke statistically to
explain the novel genes
transcriptional promiscuity means that
while the different cells of our bodies
each one might use
a certain subset of genes that it needs
in the germline
products from across the genome are
produced
genes that would could would belong to
any tissue could be
transcribed in the germline
and from a traditional perspective which
of course did not predict or expect this
it's also you know there is not a clear
explanation why would this be and how
come there are
adaptations that compensate for it and
make it so that it's not disrupted
but according to my theory
multiple genes must interact in the
determination of mutation
this mutation must affect evolution
therefore it must occur in the germline
therefore we would expect that it
involves genes of all categories of any
kind of
tissue should be able to interact in the
germline to affect mutation
and so you would expect genes of all
categories to be transcribed
in the germline which is exactly what we
what we see
right um
this is not the only fundamental
difference between the genetics of
germline and soma
there is also alternative splicing
promiscuity there's also global
hypomethylation that's involved
in transcriptional primary security and
a specialized rna interference system
that that we know to be involved in
complex regulation of transposable
elements and some argue uses them to
implement genetic
change this a lot of this is quite
recent knowledge and we
we spoke about the importance of
transposable elements to evolution so
you know everyone would agree with just
a minute of thought that all these
phenomena are of
great importance for enabling evolution
as we know it
the point is from a traditional
perspective why is it that all of these
phenomena take place precisely
in the germline precisely where their
evolutionary potential
is fulfilled so for my theory
it makes sense we have a way of
addressing this
because it predicts mutational writing
activity in the journal
uh quickly about the junk dna and encode
debate
again one of the major criticisms was
that
only so much material could be subject
to selection
and and in a sense repeating what nick
barton presented
in in the previous talk but saying it
in slightly different words when
selection acts on genetic contractions
the change in allele frequency uh would
be inconsistent in its direction
and so it may not um this this
is this is my own addition it may not
be easily distinguishable from drift and
so what looks to us through the lens of
traditional theories
neutral genetic variation can actually
be experiencing selection and
interaction that may have
a much adaptive potential it's a work in
progress with
uh eric chastain uh costas the skalakis
and chris's favorite ritual suggests
that
more genetic variation is maintained
when selection acts on interactions
as opposed to additive variants and
here is here is a nice piece
my theory predicts that there is what i
call a mutation writing phenotype so
um just like the traits of our bodies
are determined by complex genetic
interactions
that are evolved and continually
evolving so is mutation
determined by complex genetic
interactions that are evolved and
continually evolving
and what follows is that just like um
the traits of our bodies should be more
similar
between more related entities that would
be more similar
within a population than between
populations would be more similar within
one species than between species right
in the same way mutational tendencies
would be like that
too they would also be more similar the
closer the relatedness and for this
there is a
great deal of evidence that is not
really attended to
or discussed or addressed by previous
theory
so for example uh hemoglobin s mutation
was the first mutation to be described
on a molecular level
and uh and it's become a quintessential
example of
evolution by accidental mutation natural
selection taught in classes and written
in textbooks
so many of us you know grew up thinking
that
by accident this mutation happened and
the rest is his election
but evidence suggests that hbs serves at
least four independent times in africa
so one might say well okay maybe the
mutation rate is is high enough so
it occurred many independent times and
then was also selected
independent times the problem is
that take the hbe mutations is a
different
mutation involved with malaria
resistance it seems to have
appeared at least twice in asia but hbe
seems to never have appeared we presume
in africa and hbs never in asia so
if the mutation rate is high enough why
is it that
that hbs appears multiple times
independently in africa but never in
asia and hbe
multiple times in asia but not in africa
so maybe it's just a statistical fluke
or something else
the problem is that this is actually a
general pattern
so when you look at the evidence which
you're not going to find in uh you know
in
uh jtb or the journal evolution or
um the journals we we we usually uh
i look at from an evolutionary
perspective you see this in journals
like
blood right because this is about
malaria and these people are collecting
the actual evidence
and they have not been talking to
evolutionary others and this is what it
looks like
so for example the uh the deletion
mutation uh
the alpha thalassemia deletion mutation
minus alpha 4.2
appears to have uh appeared six times
independently in
melanesia only while a different
mutation minus alpha 3.73
has been found in other parts of oceania
only and the
minus alpha 3.71 appeared to have
risen three times independently and is
most common in the mediterranean in
africa and then the g2c mutation and the
first intron of the beta globin gene
appears to have uh appeared multiple
times in asia and indonesia whereas
another mutation uh appears to have
arisen multiple times in people of
african and
mediterranean origin and multiple rare
dominant beta thalassemia mutations
in the third axon of the beta globin
gene
are observed specifically and we're
currently in northern europeans and then
uh among them specifically the g2t
mutation conan 121
of the third exon appeared recurrently
there whereas other common mutations in
that same place appear in other
populations in the world and so
okay you know let's try to find the
traditional explanation maybe
the probabilities of origination of all
of these mutations
are the same for all humans but in
different geographical regions there are
different mixtures of the malaria
parasite
causing different mutations to be fixed
because maybe they provide different
resistance tailored to different
parasites but
we know that in neighboring villages in
the malaria belt that have ethnicities
that do not mix
we see very different spectra of
mutations even though the parasites are
the same
so okay maybe the probabilities are all
the same for all humans
but the different costs and benefits due
to different genetic backgrounds lead to
the fixation of different mutations
okay this is nice it makes sense but it
just doesn't give us a parsimonious
explanation
for the many many facts of the situation
take a look we actually know that the
genetic background and mutational
mechanisms are affecting the origination
of malaria resistant mutations
okay so the
alpha telescene mutations for example or
cause my nano
homologous recombination that we know is
a complex mechanism that depends on the
genetic
background of the organism so we we
actually know that here is uh
another example of a mutation that
a beta thalassemia mutation
that that
appears in the particular
location where dna structure exposes
that location to
it to um and makes genetic change more
likely in it
so we see that uh dna sequence and
structure and complex mechanisms are
affecting these mutations and
on and on the arguments go that
basically show
that that an accidental mutation
explanation doesn't
does not give us a personal explanation
for all of these facts
instead the simple explanation
is that mutation has a complex genetic
component
and this has implications that are
relevant to real world
important topics for example we talked
about the differences between germline
and suma
and we know that or it was observed by
a founder one of the founders of cancer
research
that cancer cells imitate germline cells
and especially sperm in many respects
including
global hypomethylation production of
gonadotropin expression of cancer testis
antigens
down regulation of major is the
compatibility complex and immunovasion
power of proliferation of these cells
and other things and this
great cancer researcher lloyd bald
concluded
that cancer involves activation of a
cometogenic program
so if all is correct and if i am correct
then the ethiology of cancer involves
activation of the evolutionary
mutational machinery that normally
operates
in the germline and interestingly we
know that cancer cells are exceptionally
mutationally active
health cells have been called non-human
after 40 years of evolution in the dish
here is the cardiotype of the normal
human cell an example of the karyotype
of the hela cell
they are very different one last thing
i want to end with darwin in the origin
of species
in the chapter dedicated to the laws of
variation
in the first paragraph of this chapter
darwin wrote that to say that variations
are due to chance is a holy
incorrect expression but it serves to
acknowledge plainly our ignorance of the
cause of each particular
mutation and in this chapter he
continues to provide many examples many
pieces of evidence that would not
fit in an easy way with the idea of
accidental mutation
for example what has been under intense
election pressure in recent evolutionary
times continues to vary
intensely between individuals today
from the perspective of accent mutation
you know
variation is supposed to hit where it
hits selection is supposed to act where
it acts
and there should not be a relationship
between the two
so why and uh
darwin just stated from a long array of
facts
uh he was convinced that this was a rule
of high
generality and darwin uses these words
sparingly
high generality he was convinced
um from this observation alone
one could have inferred that something
is guiding the variance
because if if things continue to vary
today that have been under intense
selection
in recent evolutionary time then it
implies that there must also be parallel
variation between related species
which we know is true for molecular
evolutionary data and from darwin's
observations
but this parallel variation cannot
continue forever because species should
in time evolve apart more and more
so something it must be there guiding
the variance
and this thing must itself be evolving
darwin called this generative
variability and i call it the mutation
writing phenotype
um and so this is uh basically uh
basically it you can see
much more details um
other kinds of evidence predictions uh
in my
paper published in biology direct
2013 and
and just keep in mind the point is
addressing many diverse facts that have
not been addressed before from a
unifying perspective
that's the strength of the proposal and
while addressing them from unifying
perspective
it brings up new directions for research
such as cancer research
new predictions and so on and that's
that's about it
i have a question yeah this sounds a bit
fantastic in some sense
um but um you know genes want to get
into the next generation
so genes now sort of influence how they
get into the next generation
what is the new genes can act selfish
right if genes are the driver
what is the counter force to uh to
account for fairness between all genes
in a genome saying we all go in this
together
yeah what i'm saying so you know yeah
yeah it could go awry very quickly
so so you know uh unfortunately for
right now but
fortunately in general yeah you know the
question you're raising is really
opening up you know a whole
other huge uh area which is how does
this um
you know what what can we learn from
this too this question of of uh
of selfishness versus cooperation at
whatever scale look at it with its
individual scale or
or the genetic uh level and it has a lot
to say about it but uh
time doesn't okay it doesn't allow thank
you for the
wonderful question um
um can i that was probably the best talk
i've been to in quite a while
okay um but i think you're wrong to say
it's your theory
because i mean it's quite a new wheel
but i think you've reinvented it in a
nice way um because this is basically
you're talking about the evolution of
involvability and there
are many nice examples in addition to
the ones you've given so
um the clustering of transcription
factor binding sites in order to
shape the genotype like map or
non-trivial neutrality and all this kind
of stuff
these are so right right so so
so thank you for this wonderful question
uh
i i would have loved it if i was was uh
you know taking a wheel and redoing it
more nicely
uh that that would have been uh a bit
easier
and it would have been nice um here is
the answer so
evolvability i'll tell you how in what
sense i agree with it
and in what sense i'm presenting
something different okay
so the sense in which i agree with it is
that evolution evolvability
and this is not built in your sense you
know
um evolvability exists
from my perspective it it is a
fundamental thing
so i agree it exists question is our
understanding of it and how it comes up
so the previous proposals
you know implicitly or explicitly
what what did they say about the origin
of this evolvability
i don't know i would presume that that
at least implicitly
people think that that you know
ultimately you have a source of
variation that
is accidental mutation under selection
and then
maybe you bring to bear on this uh group
selection
at whatever level or you do other things
and you examine it with modifier theory
and
you know a lot of wonderful work is
being done but it's very different in
nature from work that says
that mutation is fundamentally a
computational process of information
transmission
have you heard that being said in the
evolvability
uh ideas that have been proposed before
besides the one of less valiance which
uses a volatility in a different sense
i think that's true so for example the
work of mark ii
okay which talks about non-trivial
neutrality
there you have a situation where you're
actually
learning exploration distributions and
genotypes
that produce um uh grandchildren with
higher
fitness isolated thoughts that's what
the outer verb was talking about so this
is a
various adaptations for structure so so
okay so so evo
evolvability you know i i read i read
okay
i read the evolvability you know uh
literature
i i don't recall the particular
interesting paper they're mentioning i
would love to read it too
um you know it is clear that it's a
different
literature than what i'm proposing they
do agree
that uh that that there are
uh that there could be mechanisms
influencing mutation
but the philosophical framework is very
different here it's one that's based on
genetic interactions and mutation is a
computational information transmission
event
this puts together empirical phenomena
that have not been put together before
in this way the role of sex and
evolution genetic interactions
the way we use accidental chance in
evolution from this
follows you know a proposed
understanding of many different
empirical phenomena and
new predictions and new directions for
research that we're raising
so that that's that's really all and uh
yes
you claim in one of the slides uh that
um the notion of
the role of change in evolution is not
amenable to scientific studies
if i am not misconstrued okay so um
honestly i think this is not correct
but it's not only amenable to science
but it has been studied in a very
specific manner
and in particular as highlighted by nick
in his
talk in the theory of genetic drift and
importantly the drift load and equally
importantly what has been
not not mentioned in nick's talk that
version of the dream fresh competition
recently introduced questions
like urge so i think it's not only a
manner
but it has been investigated and
specific bounds can be imported
that's that's one thing okay and maybe
maybe i'll present another second
yeah so so so thank you for this
wonderful question because it allows me
to make an important correction
uh what you said in my opinion is
exactly right so let me let me try to
clarify and qualify what i was trying to
say
um random genetic drifting has been
studied
uh so much you know we are trying all
the time also to distinguish
between mutations under selection and
neutrality
but with the tools that we have that we
have had so far
so yes in that sense you know we are
trying to study the role of of chance
okay
so what i meant is the following when we
observe phenomena
that a side observer who who is not
you know encumbered with ideas that we
carry with us since the 1930s
examples that such a side observer looks
in and says this this is really strange
uh such as the novo genes
what do we do
really the response uh has been
okay so that must be due to chance after
all and what i mean by this is that
you know there is no we're not putting a
line we're not putting a boundary that
says you know
once we start invoking chants for these
please you know take us aside and
you know don't pay attention we're not
putting that line
so when jacob says in 77 you know there
shall be no de novo genes now
we see things that look as though that's
what they are so okay that's chance two
so there is there is no there is no
quantification there is no measure in a
sense
this undermines our theoretical efforts
because we have
all this extensive you know population
genetic theory that is so wonderful and
so well developed and yet
it doesn't address that question that
lies
you know behind this at the basis of of
things
which is you know how likely is this
explanation how likely is it for the
nova gene
to appear by chance we don't have the
calculation we don't have evidence
and so we presume that that from what we
see
that must be because and that's what i
mean to say that
we cannot place such a line no matter
how many models we have
there is something here that is
dangerous because you know
there is something that's irrefutable we
see the data that is strange
the nova genes transposable elements
putting together networks and we say
okay
you know there's some selection in there
and the rest is random genetic drift
and we explained but we don't know if
that's true
okay so three more questions all
together yours plus three more
theory quite a number of times usual
great news usually my [ __ ]
theory
is that this is some kind of equation
some kind of all
set of applications a system of patients
some kind of relationships
that either face the data or some kind
of data
or not and if it doesn't it
says specified and something else needs
to be developed
so could you present some very hyper
very hypothetical experiments or models
that could refute your theory yes so so
so first is to the definition of theory
that you use
which is you know present present a
certain equation a certain model and
show
you know a quantitative prediction uh
and by that you just defined
theory but that definition of theory you
know would mean the darwin's theory of
natural selection was not a theory
so so so okay that that implies that
theories are not
the only important things in science so
that implies that from your terminology
yeah yeah so from your terminology you
would like you would have liked me to
change the word theory into another word
my ultimate interest my ultimate
interest is to try to help the progress
of science in the best way that i can
that's it
so we'll defer this to this afternoon
so um in my framework the
if you have differences in the kind of
composition offspring you produce
you can think of those that genetic very
in the different
composition is within the realm of
modifier theory
but so it sounds to me what you're
proposing is basically
smart modifiers that are that are
varying something far more sophisticated
than typical mutation rate recombination
rate
it's a much more intricate variation in
the production of offspring
would you agree with that kind of
framework um
you know i mean yes and now so in one
sense there you can think about it like
that
as a very complex situation with
modifiers and you know affecting things
by epistemic interactions and not single
modifier that has a single effect of its
own that's one important yeah
you know difference and and uh you know
there are other important differences
like the the basic uh
the basic idea and the basic
understanding that is that is presented
right so
you know we are talking here about
information flow across loci
over evolutionary time so you know we
need to capture that
i believe that les valions uh framework
is extremely interesting for us in
theoretical biology because it
offers new tools with which to uh to try
to capture
such things
so you know in one sense you can
think about things in this way but it
won't be enough to capture what i'm
proposing
so as far as the applicability goes um i
can't figure out where my theory and i'm
going to say my theory both in eugene
sense of theory
and the regular sense of mind uh in
terms of
how do noble genes occur am i
categorized as accidental
i mean there's a huge so so so i i will
let you answer your question but but
i'll remind you how you answered that
yes today
um you you you said at some point
that you know we now know that even
whole genes can arise by accident
so maybe that's your answer to it no no
that was my death i mean
under your philosophical definition of
chance or accident and forget about what
how i define those terms
in the way that you define those terms
where does my theory fit in
okay so uh i mean if you want to hear
that first of all you know i'm
fascinated by the work that you're doing
we obviously share a great interest in
this topic
and i think that it's what you're doing
is very important you're producing all
this you know evidence
that i find extraordinarily relevant and
important i think that we differ in our
perspective on the meaning and
and causation of this where i would
uh predict or propose at the general
level
that it's not simply a read through
error that allows for
traditional selection to come in a
little bit before the time
when this product is experiencing
selection as we thought it should
but that this data reflects
uh more complicated events that take
place over evolutionary time
that in a general sense represent the
flow of information
across loci if you want me to give you
the details of this
i have no idea the point is for science
to go on
and study this i'll give you an example
one answer let me give let me give you a
piece of an answer okay
uh we know that the novel genes we know
that transposable elements are important
for the novel genes
so that's shown by the data there are
more they are more important
for the nova genes than the papers uh
currently uh uh even
even uh uh report on because when you
look at at those genes more than before
you see yet more transposable elements
underlying that activity
a transposable element in one you know
general sense it is a flow of
information across the left side right
so the question is are we gonna are we
gonna address all of these observations
as specific
unique questions where we say let's
think about the nova genes on their own
and say okay maybe it's the read through
era
that increases the probability for a new
uh whole gene to rise by chance
and we will address the question of
transposable elements on its own
and say that you know maybe we should
conceive them as you know parasites that
move around and by chance they get
adopted here and there or are these
really pieces of much more
uh complex and sophisticated machinery
that is operating
in the germline uh that is affecting
evolution and is part of evolvability in
a way that we haven't thought about it
before but in a way that means
information flow across los angeles side
that connects different empirical
observations and opens up
directions and predictions these are two
interesting questions
the expression of the genes rather than
actual genetic exchanges
it's not important intensive but those
are
really highly correlated with
environment and
non-randall but so
in cancer we have two parts you have to
more clear about then i mean it's
correct in cancer generally it's
horrible a lot of the effects are
the environment like that non-random
and like that might be like half and
half mutations
like the change of phenotypes might not
be exactly a mutation yeah
yeah yeah so so so none of this you know
none of this uh
well none of this interferes in any way
with what i try to uh to to state which
is
they can actually they can actually keep
on the individual
individual resistant cells and
include the gene expressions and see
then the mutation happens
and the mutations
most mutations are not very random
they're very correlated with all this
happening
majority of mutations happen and very
supposed to happen
resistant genes will change
question i don't understand most the
words being used but i also don't
understand the examples okay
so this is a concrete example of lee's
lead question which is a yes no
question we have enormous number of dna
polymerases 20 of them they have very
different profiles of errors
they're controlled by a large number of
genes and presumably the error rates and
profiles of these vary from species to
species
is that an example of what you're
talking about so once you've phrased it
in terms of
error you're introducing your
interpretation into it i'm not
introducing an interpretation is that an
example or not
no interpretations yes no question if
you want to change the word error to
change genetic change
yeah these are causing genetic exchanges
these are causing
what i'm saying is that genetic change
and what i'm saying is a genetic the
origination of genetic change
may not be accidental and that might
change fundamental concepts
it's a question here's a specific
biological mechanism specifically that
goes on
it would seem to me to be in your
framework it's a bunch of genes that
come together
they determine which polymerase is used
those polymerases have changed over time
well anyway i think thanks very much
thanks for the questions